Deathwish is directed by Eli Roth and is
the remake of the Charles Bronson film
and stars Bruce Willis as a surgeon
stars Bruce Willis as a surgeon that's
gonna sound weird no matter what and
this film follows the adventures of a
man who faces tragedy when some thugs
break into his house and he decides to
become a vigilante a public Avenger of
sorts who goes out in the streets of
Chicago in the middle of the night
looking for thugs to hopefully kill
let's just get the obvious out of the
way really fast just about every single
review that I have seen or read for this
film has to mention that it has really
bad timing our nation's conversation
right now isn't quite ready for a movie
like this I would say to be dropped this
weekend it's not the greatest timing in
regards to the way the nation is feeling
about certain events recently that being
said I don't think that's a valid
criticism because to suggest that a film
is bad simply because it came out at the
wrong time also seems to hint that there
is a right time to release a film like
this that five years ago or five years
in the future
Eli Roth's death wish would somehow be
magically better the film isn't bad
because of the timing of its release
it's bad because it sucks this is a
really generic poorly paced action
comedy drama that can't decide what it
is it's filled with a ton of needless
exposition from radio show hosts and
podcast hosts enter splice throughout
the film it feels like someone made a
movie and then someone else found the 4k
video downloader app went on YouTube and
found a bunch of videos of people
talking about gun violence and other
issues that the nation has discussed and
somehow put them throughout the movie to
attempt to give the film some kind of
deeper wait and that's really the only
time that Eli Roth's film tries to be
anything other than a typical revenge
movie and I like a good revenge movie I
am actually a pretty big fan of revenge
films and this one doesn't really do it
for me though because a lot of the
performances are incredibly wooden Bruce
Willis is a brick wall in this movie the
opening scene features a police
officer that was shot that's rushed into
ER and Bruce Willis like touches his
neck and he's like I actually thought
from the opening scene that his
character had a grudge against police
officers and that that's why he was
showing no emotion but no it's actually
just his performance he's really wooden
in this film and most of the performers
are as well everyone in the film seems
to be playing a parody of what you would
expect from their actor personas Bruce
Willis is just old guy in hoodie with
gun Dean Norris plays a cop what a
stretch if you're a Breaking Bad fan
like me it's not that strange to see
Dean Norris as a scene shooing cop who
likes to take people's pizza slices
there's also no clear antagonist there's
just an endless series of various thugs
as a surgeon he has the opportunity to
see gunshot wound victims and people who
come in kids who were harmed by thugs on
the street and he asks them questions
and then tries to figure out if he can
go find that person and murder them in
broad daylight and in 2018 when everyone
has a camera in their pocket and there
are security cameras on the corner of
virtually every street especially in a
gigantic city like Chicago it's
hilarious to me that just because he has
a hoodie on keeps him free from being
discovered after the tragedy he suffers
we get a montage that basically shows
that he's very sad and he doesn't like
the fact that the police aren't giving
him any answers and then we get this
hilarious scene where he meets his
father-in-law who scares some poachers
away with a gun and we were like
dollying in on Bruce Willis and he's
like oh I like how he did that I'm gonna
do that too
I it was hilarious I'm sorry this movie
has so many funny parts and it doesn't
know exactly what it's trying to be some
of the death scenes were so over-the-top
I was laughing and the problem is I
don't know if Eli Roth was trying to go
for that is he trying to make a film
that's actually a searing drama about a
suffering man who turns to vigilante
justice or is he making a 1980s VHS
that's out of print that you can only
find on eBay for like $65 and you watch
it and it's not even
entertaining it's a film that tries to
have a message by inter splicing radio
show hosts and podcast hosts talking
about their opinion on gun violence but
that's all they just ask a bunch of
questions the actual film doesn't try to
solve any of these questions or present
a meaning or a message of any kind it's
also a strangely funny film with a ton
of red herrings that lead to nowhere and
there's not a single memorable action
scene it's a mishmash of tones filled
with wooden performances a very boring
lead character and no clear-cut villain
I'm gonna give death wish adhi this is
just a boring revenge drama if they were
going to make a straightforward fun
revenge shoot-'em-up movie okay make
that but don't try to also have it be a
drama don't try to have a message don't
try to have it be funny just pick a tone
and run with it guys thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]